goo
今回のプレゼンのテーマは今人
ワンワールド
日本らした日本らしいおもてなしって何か出来ないだろうか
日本のはの力で世界を一つにできないだろうか
そしてそれをこの着物で表現できないだろうか
そういったことをお話ししていきたいとおもいます
日本らしさ日本人日本
当たり前のように使っている言葉ですが
改めてその意味ってなんでしょうか
皆さんはご自身が日本人だと意識されたことはありますか
世界っていったいなんでしょうか
私が自分が日本人だなぁと意識したのは大学時代でした
当時設立2年目だった
立命館アジア太平洋大学通称 apu をいた県別府市にあります
ご覧のように
た課題にあったので
天候が悪いと霧が立ちこめ
10メートル先も見えない学校も休校になるようなそんな山の上の大学です
この学校のその霧は
学校の下に広がるのでまるで雲の上に浮かんでいるようで私たち学生はキャンパスの
ことを
天空と呼んでいます
学祭も天空祭と言うんですけど
この下の方に広がる別府の市街地のことは下界と呼んでいます
でこの大学には
世界各国80カ国約80カ国から留学生が集まっていました
国際学生が学生の約半数で教員も外国籍
そんな特異な環境で過ごした4年間はかなり濃いものです
新しい大学に集うような人たちなので
好奇心旺盛で積極的でかなりキャラ六穀丁
衝突も絶えません
ただ仲良くなるのにその人が何人かとかどんな言語を話すのかとか
男性か女性か
血液型が何が高そういったものは一切関係ありませんです
それでも講義の中では国際問題などについてディスカッションするのでその中で
やっぱり日本人としてお前はどう思うんだとそういった立場が求められました
初めてそこで日本を意識したんですが
日本ってどんな国かなぁと
村月何も考えてなかった自分がいてすごく恥ずかしい思いをしそれから日本文化や日本
の歴史を改めて考えるきっかけになります
そしたらやっぱり日本って素晴らしい国だなと日本の精神制定
すごくいいものだなぁと思って初めてやっぱり日本人として誇りを持った瞬間でもあり
ます
着物もその一つです
ちょうど大学を卒業して10年になるんですが2020年には東京オリンピックの開催
も決定しました
せっかくの機会なので世界に向けて世界をもっと身近に感じたい
何か残したいそう思っています
希久美さんの話をいつも聞くとすごいいろんな体験をされているんだなっていつも思い
ます
日本人として自分を見直した時に着物があったんだなっていう話もよく聴かせてもらい
ました
私にとって着物とはもうこれから離れられない
いつも大事な気持ちとかを教えてくれる大事なものになります
自己紹介も花へと話しさせていただきたいと思います
私は今まで頑張ったことも頑張りたいと思ったことも何もなく
高校卒業後自動車関係の向上に努めで平凡に生活していました
もともと着物は好きだったんですでもいつからかどうしてこんなに着物は綺麗なん
だろうって思うようになったんです
どうしても気になってあるとき sns で知り合った厩舎の着物屋さんが京都にあの
着物を作る工程を見に行くって聞いたときに私は図々しくも同行させてもらったんです
その時に私は初めて知りました綺麗な着物には理由があるっていうことを
それは職人の人たちのこだわりだったり
技術だったり思いがたくさん詰まってたんです
私はその日しとっても感動しました
今の時代情報は触れて本物のように作られるものってたくさんあると思うんです
着物もその一つなんですインクジェットで染められる着物もあります
私も今まで知りませんでした
着物って一括りでしたでもこんな世界の人から見ても誰から見ても着物はきれいだねっ
て言ってもらえるのはこういう作りねの人たちがいるからだということを知ったんです
私はその違いを初めて知りました
この時何度も何度も涙が溢れるくらい感動したんですけどとても悲しいことも知ったん
です
それは
作り手の高齢化それと後継者不足だったんです
なんでこんなにきれいなものなのになくなってしまうかもしれないんだろうってわかり
ませんでした
でもその理由は
安物が出回ってたりとかあのーそうすることによって仕事に皆さんしなくなっていった
んです
私はその時このままじゃいけないって本当に思いました
でそれで初めて人生初めて覚悟を決めたんです
それから私は工場の仕事を辞めて
8置物餌に努めることにしましたそれで初めて私は親元を離れて世界日本一
あの着物を愛しているあの呉服屋さんに勤めることになったんだ
そうなんですか着物って日本の文化の一つなんですけどまぁ日本民俗衣装でもあると
思うんですけど
こういうふうに一人の人生を変えてしまうくらい魅力的な不思議なパワーがあるんだな
それからためて
私も実際に制作過程を見学させていただいたことがあるんですけれども
もう本当に a
やっぱりこういうふうに着物を着るだけとか見るだけでは味わえない
作る工程でしか味わえない感動とか
があって見直すきっかけにもなります
一緒にいた a ちょうど行った時はですね
着物がこの布に描かれる前の
死体の図案のラフの打ち合わせの時だったんですけれども
まあ一緒に行った依頼主の方だったり
この造り手の方線職人さん達っていうのは長いことをこの仕事をされているので
こだわりが強くてかなり意見がぶつかってですねこの着物で
何を表現するかとかどう表現するかというのがそれぞれ違うので本当に真剣にもう
ちょっと若干喧嘩かなっていう入り
あの箱花1だったりその大きさとかそういう細かいところまでかなり議論されています
そういう着物っていうのを触れる中でですね
てっきり私着物が一人の職人さんが始めから終わりまでやってるもんだと思ってたん
ですけどその工程て約少なくても20校艇あって本当にたくさんの人が関わってたん
ですね
マッコイ部ご覧のように
その工程の中でまぁもうほとんどの人の持ったまえというのが世に出ることはなくて
それでも文句をいう人も
まあ自分があったんだって必要以上に誇張する人もいなくてそういう協業だったり
あの
チームプレイとかお互いをたたえ合ったり尊重しあうっていうのは本当に日本らしい
って思いました
チームプレーは世界各国あるんですけれども特に日本ってそういうのが強いんじゃない
かなと
刑部さんは着物でね毎日過ごしてるんですけど良いものに触れ合ってるんですけど何か
印象的だか出来事とかありますあります毎日結構刺激的なんですけどこの前社長とお客
様に社長のお客様に合わせてもらった時私は理解できないことがあったんですそれは
その
客様は生まれたお孫さんのためにですね
お振袖をお求めになってたんです私はそのお降りさではすごく効果で素敵なものだった
んですけどどうして今なんだろうへ理解できませんでした
なって成人式は20年後だし早く歯落ちたとしても10何年後にはなるわけだし
なんで今なんだろうとわからなかったんですでもそこにはですねすごいそのお客様の
温かい気持ちがこもってたんです
それは自分が20年までこのほか20年になる
20才になるまで生きられるかは
からないだけどこの想いをですね形に何か残していきたい
健康で二十歳を迎えてほしいこんな素敵なお振袖がにゃんこになってほしい
たくさんの温かいお気持ちが詰まっていました
今は成人式でもレンタルかがすごく進んでいます
でも着物って私は衣装ではないと思うんです
自分も成人式の時は
まあレンタルだったんですけどでもその時は何も疑問に思っ思いませんでした
でも祖母の気持ちがですね今こうやって形に何かあればもっと幸せだったのになと思う
んです
着物って作り手の方もお前がたくさん
困ると思うんですけどを送る側にもすごく気持ちがこもるものなんだなって最近知った
ことでしたね
まさに気持ちが乗るもので着物ですね
私たちがこれそれぞれきているこの1枚にも本当にたくさんの想いとかたくさんの人が
関わっているんですけれども実はこの着物はそれぞれある国をテーマにデザインされて
いるんですけれども
どこの国だかお分かりになりますか
感ないですよね体へ私が着ているのは南アフリカ共和国で
南アフリカ共和国って不毛の大地でです
なかなか草花が育ちにくいんですけれども奇跡の2週間って言われる期間があってその
時だけ高山地帯にたくさんの花が咲き見られるんですよ
それの花の中のこの者からンター
このピークのプロペアこの極楽鳥花
そういったものを表現していない
この国はアパルトヘイトが廃止されて
撤廃されて本当にたくさんも人種の人が共存してるんですけれどもそれをこのたくさん
の花で表現しています
重ねローケツ染めというロー何回も重ねる
日本にもうその先生しかいない貴方で作っています
私が着ているのはオセアニアの小さな島国ツバルの着物です
着物のテーマは美し空と
後海になります裾の方をよく見てください
第一が水色になっているんです
これは木原先生がこれは沈み行く津軽をイメージしています
地球温暖化が進んで回数面が上昇していますそのためにつばらの人々も毎年10%して
います
ものすごく悲しいことだと思うんです
この着物をつくってくれた木原先生はとても優しくて温かい先生でした
私のきくみさんも本当に大好きな先生でした
でも木原先生はもういないんです
昨年の11月8日に亡くなってしまいました
それと同時にこの優しくてでも力強い品ももうなくなってしまったんです
今2カ国をご紹介させていただきましたがあと4カ国でしていてですね
合計6か国の置物が今完成していますこれは私たちは2020年東京オリンピックまで
に
196か国世界にはあるんですけど196枚
いろいろな国を思い表現し作り上げたいと思っています
簡単にご紹介させていただきたいと思います
ヘッドを塗ったっ
ブラジル
いかんよ共和国
方
この合計6か国の着物を一足先に
昨年の11月8日奇しくもキャラ先生が亡くなられた日に
東京都日本橋開かれたきものサローネという超にて披露させていただきますと
各国の大使館の人にもあの観ていただいたんですけれども中でもこの南アフリカ共和国
の大使の方のコメントがすごく感動的で
本当にこういった
日本でいう桜っていうのが描かれてていう感動したっていうお話を聞いて
私たちの方が胸が熱くなります
このインタビューの様子が国際ニュースで全世界に流れて本当に大変な反響いただいた
んです
そういうふうに作り手の想いとかそれを贈る人の思いとか
こうやって受け取ってくださる方の思いそこに乗る思いというのはきっと伝わるんだ
なぁとそれはもう人種とか文化とかそういうものは関係なくて国境を飛び越えていくん
だなぁと改めて思いました
おばあさまが贈られたお孫さんへの思いだったりとかそういうふうに私たちは着物に
その国のことを知って調べてその国の素晴らしいところをたたえてそれを想いを馳せ
ながらこんな
こういうふうに着物に表現していきたいと思っています
日本
は
五輪オリンピックです五大陸
リング
ピンク
つながる日本のは
平和世界平和
世界平和というと壮大なテーマすぎてすごく遠いことのように感じますが
もう本当にそこにいるのは世界に住んでるのは一人の人間で今回のでて口水のテーマの
ようにドットその.の人がたくさん集まっているのが地球です
そこに二種の違い文化の違い価値観の違いは関係なくて本当にみんなひとりの人間なの
で
ただそれだけのシンプルなことだと思います
国と国と人の人との間には争いはこれからも完全になくなることはないと思うんです
でも美しいものとかとうとう妹のかけがえのないものは
そんな人によって違うものではないと思います
だからこそ世界は一つになれるとそう信じています
よかったら会場の皆さん席を立っていただけませんか
お隣の人と
手をつないでくださいちょっと家買ってきましたます
想像してくださいこういうふうにお隣の人と繋いだこの手のはが世界に広がっていくの
想像してください
196か国この規模の頭が蒸れ
平等に一列に並んで世界が一つになる姿
日本の文化を通して伝えたい日本の文化の着物をとして伝えたい
なぜならこの日本らしさのその先に
平和へのヒントがあると思うからです
私たちのこの気持ちを形にしていきたい
たくさんの人の英知と
情熱を集めながら unknown 本当にたくさんの人が関わってやってくれている
んですね
なのでこれからもぜひ皆さんでこの平和のメッセージを世界にと私たちと一緒に広げて
いき
いただきたいなと思います
イマジンマンワールド
世界はきっと一つになれる
そんな
未来をここ日本から一緒に世界に広げていきましょう以上です
どうもありがとうございますありがとうございました